[music] the
european union imposed sanctions on
russia in response to its actions to
destabilize the situation in ukraine
these actions include the violation
of ukrainian sovereignty and
russia's illegal annexation of crimea and sevastopol the
flow of fighters and weapons from the territory of the
russian federation
eastern ukraine the measures are a
tool of foreign policy they are not
are directed against the Russian population
and are intended to change
Russian policy towards Ukraine the
European Union is ready to lift sanctions
and cooperate with Russia again
as soon as it begins to actively and
unambiguously
contribute to finding a solution to the
Ukrainian crisis the European Union
regularly review sanctions and
openly communicate its
decisions and sales on tv
arthur, she and prices are higher than the side,
except for all 28
European leaders unanimously
advocated that the duration of the
sanction
depend on the full implementation of the Minsk
agreements, the main point of which
is the return to Ukraine of full
control over  eastern border
[music]
asset freeze and visa bans
apply to
152 people these people are responsible for
actions that undermine the
territorial integrity and
sovereignty of ukraine
37 organizations are subject to an
asset freeze in with economic
sanctions
include restricting access to
capital markets from for Russian
state financial
arms trade embargoes and
restrictions on access to certain
sensitive technologies, in particular in the
oil industry, the European Union did not
impose a ban on the import of
agricultural products from Europe,
this decision was made by the Russian
Federation
in August 2014
[music]